I've got a really sick video to show you
today
remember when Donald Trump briefly had
that interim attorney general Matthew
Whitaker he's the guy that had no
business being Attorney General
whatsoever no credentials that would
justify being Attorney General but after
Jeff Sessions got pushed out by Trump
but before William Bar was ultimately
put in place by Donald Trump there was
this guy Matthew Whitaker
who was the interim AG Matthew Whitaker
went on the super scandalously sickening
and scummy scam of a show a judge Janine
on Fox News and he claimed that
stay-at-home Orders are equivalent to
martial law now we'll talk about martial
law in a moment here's Matthew Whitaker
and here he is telling it to judge
Jeanine who seems just riveted by this I
mean is is well-placed
to make sure that our our First
Amendment and all constitutional rights
aren't infringed unnecessarily you know
the Supreme Court has said that any
infringement on those fundamental right
has to be narrowly tailored and so
lockdown orders or keeping people in
their houses under you know what would
equate to martial law is just not
allowed and it's not going to be
tolerated by the Department of Justice
so I think you know get certain states
that are a little more restrictive I
think the Department of Justice is
painting Kenai 2 right now
lockdown orders are equivalent to
martial law so this is as good an
opportunity as any to talk about martial
law a little bit what is martial law
martial law is when the United States or
parts of it are placed under military
control often with the suspension of the
normal judicial system which is why
habeas corpus is an important aspect of
this so the president can enact martial
law federally governors can enact state
martial law one of the things that comes
with martial law is that habeas corpus
can be suspended habeas corpus is you
have a right to a hearing unlawful
imprisonment it is supervised by law
enforcement and rather the judiciary
continues to supervise the actions of
law enforcement
you can't just be indefinitely held
without being told what the charges are
against you and given relatively speedy
access to due process during martial law
the normal process due process could be
suspended meaning someone could just be
held indefinitely without charging them
including by the military which often
takes or can take a law enforcement role
under martial law
so just deploying troops domestically is
not even necessarily martial law if the
civil courts keep functioning etc it
still is not really martial law but
martial law can include courts stopped
functioning civil courts stopped
functioning the military starts playing
a judiciary role the military starts
playing a law enforcement role etc now
there are examples of when martial law
has been enacted you could look at New
Orleans in the war of 1812 you could
look at after the Chicago Fire of 1971
while the fire was being extinguished
martial law was put in place and then it
was lifted within a few days the San
Francisco earthquake of 1906 martial law
was used to start confiscating dynamite
to then destroy buildings that were in
the path of the fire to try to prevent
the fire from spreading uncontrollably
lifted within a few days so again
Matthew Whitaker says that stay at home
orders he calls them lockdowns are
equivalent to martial law first of all
the lockdown is not being enforced by
force grocery stores or open hardware
stores are open every delivery service
Amazon CVS Target they're all delivering
tens of millions or hundreds of millions
of items all around the country you can
go for a walk you can go to the hospital
it's just that you know there are some
businesses that are closed people are
advised to stay home and maintain social
distance so for someone who was Attorney
General to suggest that the lockdowns
are even remotely like martial law is
dangerous because we know that there is
a large population out there the gun
toting Trumpets types who are waiting
for martial law to go out and do really
horrible things if they believe that
martial law has been enacted by their
governor that's the important thing at
the same time
they seem very willing to turn over
control of the judiciary up to and
including a federal martial law being
enacted by their Lord and Savior Donald
Trump with not much of a realization
that during martial law oftentimes
weapons are confiscated which they claim
the government would only do over their
cold dead hands or something like that
is the way the phrase goes so there's
been only one entity by the way that has
lobbied for the suspension of habeas
corpus during all of this and it's
Trump's Justice Department I reported to
you a few weeks ago Trump's Justice
Department asked because of coronavirus
we want to be able to just hold people
indefinitely without due process because
the courts are all stopped up their
reduced capacity courts at this point in
time so the one body here that has taken
any action that would even be associated
with martial law is the federal
government it's Trump's administration
asking for the effective suspension of
habeas corpus Whitaker is acting like we
have going on here what China had where
people's doors were barred shut with
pieces of metal that were welded
together we can go out we are asked not
to do so if it's not necessary we're
asked to cover up with masks stores have
policies some here in Massachusetts
let's say you can only come into this
store with a mask stay six feet away
from people many coffee shops are even
open but for takeout only restaurants
are open take out only if this is
martial law it seems martial law is just
a lot more boring than anything else but
it is not the dystopian nightmare that
Matthew Whitaker seems to be claiming
that it is dangerous to spread the
disinformation